ここからはさらにAIエージェントの可能性を劇的に広げるツールという概念を学びます。
ということで、ツールに関してご説明をさせていただければと思いますので、画面切り替わりますが、ツールとはですね、一言で言うと
AIエージェントに与える道具のことです。 これまでのAIエージェントは、図のChat Modelとメモリ機能しか持ってませんでしたが、
ツールというのを与えることで、AIにイメージとして手足を授けるようなことができます。 具体的にはGmailであったり、Googleドライブ、
スプレッドシートであったりだとか、Slack、またNotion等ですね、様々なツール、外部サービスっていうのを与えることができるんですね。
ここで先ほどのAI Agentノードに戻っていきますが、こちらAI Agentノードの一番右の方にですね、このツールというのが
あったかと思います。 こちらからそのツールというのを追加していく形になりますので、
実際にですね、ツールというのを追加していて、AIエージェントの可能性をさらに広げていきたいと思います。
では早速ツールを追加していくので、こちらのプラスボタンを押していただいて、今回はWikipediaを追加していこうと思いますので、検索欄から
検索をしていただくと、このようにWikipediaノードを追加できますので、こちらをクリックします。
このように選択をしましたら、実際にWikipediaツールというのができましたので、実際にWikipediaをツールとして使ってくれるかどうか、ちょっとチャットの方で試してみたいと思います。
では、検索欄の方で、このようにWikipediaで織田信長について調べてと、このようにメッセージを送信します。
このようにですね、きちんとAIエージェント自身がWikipediaというツールを使って、Wikipedia上の織田信長に関する情報というのを出力してくれたかと思います。
先ほどのシステムメッセージの名残で、ちょっと大阪弁、関西弁ですね、名残があるんですけども、このようにですね、実際ツールを使うことによってAIがうまくツールを使いながら
ユーザーの入力に対して回答を出してくれるといった形になります。
Wikipedia一つもですね、十分賢くはなりましたが、さらに複数のツールを持たせた時に、どんなことをしてくれるのかというのを皆様にも体験いただければと思うので、
再度またツールの追加ボタンの方から新たなツールを追加していきたいとおもいます。
今回はGmailツール、こちらを追加していこうかと思いまして、実際にですね、やることとしては、Wikipediaで検索した内容というのを
Gmailの下書きに作成する、こういったのをやってみたいと思います。
ということで、実際にGmailツールの追加というのを行っていくんですけども、新しく使用するツールについては、Credential、認証情報の設定というのが必要となりますので、まずは認証情報の設定を行っていきます。
今、画面上ですとすでに入っていますが、皆様のお手元のパソコンの方ではですね、このCreate New Credentialというものしかないかと思いますので、こちらから認証を進めていきます。
ではこちらを開いていただくと、こういった画面ですね、認証を行うような画面が出てきますので、Gmailの連携認証については非常に楽です。
この画面のこちら、Sign in with Google、こちらのボタンを押していただくと、ページが飛びまして、このようにですね、Gmailアカウントをどれにしますか、連携するアカウントをどれにしますかという選択がありますので、
こちら任意のアカウントでおつなぎいただけたらなというふうに思います。 実際にアカウントを選択しますと、このようにですね、許可しますかというボタンが出てきますね。
きちんと忘れないようにチェックを入れていただいて、これでつなげられました。
という形になったので、最後ですね、先ほどの画面、こちらに戻りたいと思いますので、少々お待ちください。
実際にn8nの画面に戻ると、このようにですね、緑色でつながりましたよっていう表示が出たかと思います。これで連携がOKといった形ですね。
また今回は下書きの作成になりますので、そちらの設定というのを行っていく必要があります。
こちらの項目というのを設定をしていくんですが、まずはですね、大事なこのリソースというところ
開いてみるとメッセージ、ラベル、ドラフト、スレッドと書いてありますが、これは何をGmailに扱わせるか
という選択画面でして、メッセージ、これはメールってことですね。メール本文に関することなのか、またラベル機能、仕分けなのか
今回はこのドラフトですね、下書き作成といったことですので、今回はこのドラフト、下書きに関する処理というのをしてもらうように設定します。
そうしましたら続いてオペレーションの部分ですね。 選択したリソース、下書きを何するのか。
Create、作成する、Delete、削除するのか、Get、既存の下書きの情報を抽出するのか、Getメニュー、複数の下書きの情報を抽出するのか、ここを任意で設定することができます。
今回はドラフトの作成ですので、このCreateを選択してこれでOKということですね。
続いてこちらサブジェクトという部分なんですが、こちらは下書きであったりメールに関しての件名ですね。件名というのを設定することができます。
こちら任意で選択することもできますし、あるいはこういった形で例えば
ユーザーが入力した情報、プロンプトと言われるものを懸命にしたいよということであれば チャットインプットというところからこうやって持ってくることもできるんですね
さらにはですね、今回はより便利な機能を体感いただこうということで、こちらはキラキラのボタンがありますので、これを押してみたいと思います
こちらはですね、AIがいい感じに件名を作ってくれると、AIが判断していい感じに作ってくれるっていうそんな機能になります。
今回はこれで試してみたいと思いますね。
続いて、Eメールタイプ。こちらはEメールのタイプ、HTMLにするか、テキストにするのか、これも任意で選択することできます。
本日はテキストでいきたいと思いますので、テキスト。 続いてメッセージ。
メッセージはですね、メール本文ですね。こちらも任意で指定することもできますが、今回は件名同様にですね、AIにいい感じ作ってもらおうと思いますので、キラキラボタンを押して、これで設定が完了といった形になります。
ということで、実際に下書きを作成してくれるのかどうかというのを実際に体感してみたいと思いますので、
こちらのチャットの方から調べて、このように指示を出してみたいと思います。
Wikipediaで織田信長について調べ、Gmailで下書き作成。
このようにですね、処理が完了しました。
ということで、きちんと下書きが作成されたか見てみたいと思います。
画面をちょっと映りますが、こちらですね、連携した画面になるんですけども、
あ、きちんとされていますね。織田信長についての調査結果といったところが、きちんとこちらに記載があります。
これで連携ができている、連携完了といった状況になりますね。
このようにですね、複数のツールというのをつなぎ合わせて、よりAIエージェントの可能性を広げることができる、こういった機能のご紹介をさせていただきました。
またですね、考えられることとしましては、実際に今回の件でいうと、Wikipediaで検索した検索結果というのをまとめて、
要はGmailの方で下書きを作成してほしい。Wikipediaを使ったらGmailで下書き作成。この順番っていうのは基本的には守ってほしいじゃないですか。
ただですね、AIエージェントも複数のツールがあるとですね、最適なユーザーの理想とする使い方というのができないことがあるんですね。
そこで重要なのが、前回のパートでもやってたシステムメッセージです。
こちらでその旨というのを伝える必要があります。ユーザーの入力情報についてまずWikipediaで調べて、調べた内容を要約して
Gmailの下書きで作成してほしい。このようにきちんとAIエージェント自身の動きの制御というのをシステムメッセージで伝えていく
制御していくってことが非常にこの複数ツールを扱う上では重要なポイントとなりますので、これらは今後も設定が必要になってくる部分でございますので必ず押さえておくようにしておいてください。
教授としてもやっております。 また、世界でオンラインロボットメーカーとするABDグループの